[Funny Music]
Sharon Richter: I and my partner, Guy Oranim,
Management of BabyFirst company from the idea of ​​being excited about it
Creating good educational content
For infants, young children and their parents.
Today, BabyFirst apps have been downloaded more than 30 million times.
When we met the family class
In the Google Play store
We found that this exactly matches BabyFirst values
As any BabyFirst application will always provide value for families
In a way that allows the child and father / mother to interact
With age-appropriate content always available.
We noticed that parents can easily find
Content they're looking for.
Now our app downloads have increased by 40% through GOOGLE PLAY
As compared to what we do on other platforms.
That impressed us.
Yuval Richter: Allow us to test our store data card
To know exactly what works in the store
As well as attractive code and interesting video
In addition to the expressive screenshot.
For the first time, we can test it all really
With actual Android users
Just to identify the successful elements by almost 100%.
That is what matters to us.
You can use drag-and-drop.
You can customize a certain amount of data traffic
For the new experience.
So the risks are low and the gains are high.
In the application "ABC" for example, when we tested the symbols
Try using a bold or light colored icon when compared to the surrounding area.
We also tried different colors in the same code.
We tried using two or three dimensions
In the end, we know what the user really likes
As well as what attracts the attention of users.
After testing the application of "ABC"
We noticed a 140% increase in downloads.
That was great.
[Funny Music]
In the "Play Phone" app, we tested screenshots.
We inserted a phone image into the same screenshot.
We've tweaked the text, colors, and shapes.
This has resulted in an 11% increase in search downloads.
[Funny Music]
We did something else simple
The translation of the store listing page into 10 languages.
This led to a 150% increase in search downloads
From outside the United States.
And by combining the experiences of the store
Family and translation
We can achieve a 50% increase in downloads
Through the applications we create.
Sharon: I think we are very lucky.
We work in the area we love.
And make children happy day by day.
Now we plan to create better children's apps
With also talking to their mothers
Because we are now confident
We want to make life easier for mothers.
We are very excited about the future
Because the prototype is a success
We are excited to invest that heavily.
[Funny Music]